[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
journal de l'afrique sur france 24
à la une ce soir cette attaque au mali
dans la ville garnison de cathy aux
portes de la capitale bamako au moins un
soldat a été tué les militaires au
pouvoir la tribu à des djihadistes
camicas proche d'al qaïda en tunisie les
électeurs sont appelés à se prononcer
lundi sur le projet de nouvelle
constitution voulue est définie par le
chef de l'état kaïs ayed ce projet qui
consacre la prédisant
présidentialisation du régime suscitent
des inquiétudes mais l'opposition a eu
du mal à se faire entendre vous le
verrez notamment dans les médias
reportage à suivre et puis le festival
nuits d'afrique s'achève ce week end à
montréal c'est un des plus grands
festivals d'amérique du nord consacré à
la musique africaine on retrouvera
fatimata one notre envoyé spécial
au mali à cathy dans la banlieue de la
capitale bamako je vous le disais au
moins un soldat a été tué dans une
attaque attribuée par l'armée malienne à
la katiba massina affiliés à al qaïda la
ville garnison de katy est au coeur de
l'appareil militaire c'est là que vit à
6 mio et à le chef de la junte au
pouvoir les précisions de cyril payen
ils étaient en plateau tout à l'heure
outre ces déclaration formelle et
officielle lancée par le gréement de
transition est commandée par une junte
militaire qui habite à à kati
effectivement il s'agit d'une attaque
terroriste qui est un peu curieux qui
interpelle un peu les observateurs de la
question c'est que le gouvernement de
transition a été très rapide pour
dénoncer le grand ennemi djihadistes la
katiba masinac est affilié à al qaïda et
qu'il faut lire marque beaucoup de
points dans le nord et le centre du pays
n'avaient jamais si cela était le cas
osé s'en prendre vous le disiez au coeur
symbolique du pouvoir le colonel keïta
réside à cat iq est à 15 km un peu dans
les hauteurs de bamako qui est une ville
immense garnison c'est la plus grosse
base militaire
2 du mali donc ça donne vraiment une
idée sur la portée symbolique de cette
attaque il y à aussi il faut le dire des
rumeurs persistantes
anonyme puisque c'est un peu dangereux
ce soir il ya beaucoup de volatilité à à
bamako qui soulignent le fait que du
sort il s'agirait peut-être d'une
mutinerie aussi il n'y a pas que que des
accords au sein de la junte militaire
dont beaucoup de prudence pour relater
s'est fait tout ce qu'on peut retenir
c'est qu'il n'y ait jamais eu une
attaque aussi coordonné aussi importante
et elle fait suite à une autre plusieurs
attaques cette semaine à quelque 100
kilomètres de bamako tout cela n'est
jamais arrivé depuis 2012 2012 c'était
quand la france allait intervenir pour
littéralement sauvé le mali des mains
des djihadistes des djihadistes qui sont
résolument à la main d'oeuvre en tout
cas c'est le moins qu'on puisse analyser
ce soir après ces attaques le mali que
la côte d'ivoire n'a pas l'intention de
déstabiliser c'est ce qu'a déclaré ce
vendredi le président ivoirien alassane
ouattara il s'exprimait depuis l'afrique
du sud où il est en visite officielle je
rappelle qu abidjan est en pleine
brouille diplomatique avec bamako qui a
arrêté une cinquantaine de ses soldats
accusés d'être des mercenaires on écoute
alassane ouattara
la population frères et soeurs par
conséquent il n'est pas question pour
nous de nous engager une quelconque
tentative de déstabilisation vous dit de
faire la transparence je pense que là
tout le monde regrette cette situation
et je pense qu'il faut qu'un de nos
mains
on part à présent tunisie la tunisie ou
en ont tout juste après le coup de force
du 25 juillet où le président kaïs sayed
s'est arrogé les pleins pouvoirs sa
réforme constitutionnelle est soumise
lundi à référendum ce projet qui doit
renforcer les pouvoirs du président et
affaiblir le parlement suscite des
inquiétudes mais vous allez voir que
l'opposition à rester timides le
reportage de lilia blaise et hamdi tilly
obama
nous sommes au lendemain de la
publication du projet de la constitution
tunisienne début juillet comme chaque
midi sur le plateau de midi show l'une
des émissions politiques les plus
écoutées en tunisie le chroniqueur et
c'est même lui qui se montre ironique et
n'hésite pas à critiquer la scène
politique et je continue à faire mon
travail je continue à critiquer que ce
soit le président le gouvernement
à peu près tout le monde
l'opposition également mais évidemment
je n'ai pas le moindre problème pour
exercer il appelle à la vigilance oui
les dangers existent
ils ont toujours existé pendant ces dix
ans mais aujourd'hui je conçois que il
faut être très vigilant parce que
personne ne sait de quoi
le mois prochain sera fait à la proche
du référendum le syndicat des
journalistes dénoncent les restrictions
de couverture de la campagne et un débat
très limité sur les enjeux de la
constitution
il s'est joint à d'autres associations
pour dénoncer les dérives du projet
constitutionnel de la présidence un
message fort d'une société civile qui
fait ce que
je pense que l'aspect civil aujourd'hui
à l'aller consciente des menaces de
l'avortement de processus démocratique
en tunisie pour avoir du souffle il faut
avoir du souffle et pas seulement pour
le 25 pas seulement pour le 17 décembre
prochain une mobilisation à laquelle un
acteur social et politique important ne
participe pas la centrale syndicale du
gtt qui avait durci le ton contre kei
sayed avant la publication de la
constitution et qui avait même organisé
une grève générale en jouant pour
contester la politique économique du
gouvernement a refusé de se positionner
pour ce référendum
peut-être bientôt une bouffée d'oxygène
pour le continent mais aussi pour le
reste du monde qui a fait moscou ont
signé ce vendredi à istanbul 2 accord
séparé avec la turquie et les nations
unies sur l'exportation des céréales et
produits agricoles via la mer noire
accord valable pendant quatre mois le
temps de sortir les quelques 25 millions
de tonnes entassés dans les silos
d'ukraine une bonne nouvelle pour le
kenya notamment où la famine menace à
cause de cette guerre en ukraine bien
sûr mais aussi à cause de la sécheresse
qui sévit dans le nord du pays
à deux jours de marche du village le
plus proche se trouve celui de parra
poule ça fait trois ans qu'il n'a pas
plus ici dans ce désert de poussière il
ne reste plus que des baies sauvages à
manger local cette mère de famille les
fait bouillir et les réduit en pâte amer
pour nourrir ses cinq enfants
je donne c'est bien mes enfants parce
qu'il n'y a rien d'autre à leur donner
l'unique source d'eau et ce puits
insalubres les villageois n'ont pas
d'autre choix que de le partager avec
les quelques animaux qui ont survécu à
la sécheresse à vélo nous tue elle n'est
pas propre les singes boivent dedans
elle est contaminée par des bactéries et
n'est pas potable
depuis et profond des enfants sont même
tombés dedans
trois ont été sauvées mais un enfant
s'est noyé
la corne de l'afrique connaît sa pire
sécheresse depuis 40 ans au moins 18
millions de personnes sont en situation
de faim extrême et la guerre en ukraine
n'a fait qu'empirer la situation
alimentaire
ces conditions météo extrêmement
difficile avec des saisons successives
sans pluie ont été empirée par la guerre
brutale de vladimir poutine en ukraine
qui a aggravé l'augmentation des prix de
la nourriture du carburant et des
engrais
[Musique]
l'accord en cours entre l'ukraine et la
russie permettrait de reprendre les
exportations de blé un répit temporaire
à cette crise alimentaire
en afrique du sud à la haute cour de
johannesburg le procès de certains
membres des combattants pour la liberté
économique se poursuit au coeur de ce
procès il ya une chanson intitulée kiss
the bear elle est considérée comme un
appel au meurtre par la communauté
afrikaner le reportage de caroline dumay
et nadine theron et stéphane carstens
est la haute cour de johannesburg
le procès pour incitation à la haine
raciale du leader d'extrême gauche
julius malema se base sur une chanson de
la lutte anti-apartheid
intitulé tuons les fermiers blancs
pour le groupe african air afriforum en
procès depuis février 2022 cette chanson
est un appel au meurtre l'avocat de
julius malema dément
si monsieur prins nouveau faire le lien
entre la chanson et les conséquences
psychologiques qu'ils endurent
aujourd'hui il faut qu'il le prouve il
n'y a aucune preuve que ces deux choses
soient liés
monsieur prince l'eau le voilà témoins
charge de ce procès il a perdu l'usagé
de ses jambes en 2008 quand il a été
sauvagement attaqué dans sa chambre à
coucher
quand ils ont essayé de réanimer ma
femme
j'entendais qu'elle avait beaucoup de
sang dans les poumons sa gargouilles et
puis j'ai compris qu'elle était morte
les meurtriers n'avaient pas 20 ans
alors à chaque fois qu'il voit des
jeunes entamé le champ controversé les
larmes lui montent aux yeux
tu es le fermier blanc
je n'ai vécu
ma femme a été tuée j'ai été mutilée
juste entendre ces mots me replonge dans
ses souvenirs
[Musique]
il n'a jamais réussi à revendre sa
propriété dans un pays qui compte près
de 400 attaques de ferme tous les ans
pour cet analyste l'utilisation
populiste de ses chansons historiques
pourrait être contre-productif
les combattants économie que sont la
liberté aka prête mal la situation en
afrique du sud
ce que leur façon théâtrale de faire la
collecte leur apportera des votes au
bingo boxe après toutes ces années on
semble toujours bloquée pour cent des
voix
le verdict est attendu dans les semaines
qui viennent
l'afrique du sud récompensé hier lors
des caf awards ce désir ellis a été
désigné entraîneur de l'année pour la
troisième édition consécutive elle
entraîne les joueurs sud-africaine qui
affronteront demain samedi les
marocaines lors de la finale féminine de
l'as cannes 2022 écoutez sa réaction
c'est un prix d' équipe car en tant que
coach on travaille avec l'équipe et si
l'équipe réussit l'individu se
distinguent
je dédie donc ce prix à mon équipe de
banyana et aux entraîneurs qui encadrent
le football féminin
et la finale de cette coupe d'afrique
des nations féminine elle se tiendra
demain samedi à rabat au maroc et enfin
par au canada montréal où le festival
nuits d'afrique s'achève ce week end il
fait depuis trente six ans la part belle
aux grands noms de la scène musicale
africaine et caribéenne on retrouve sur
place notre envoyé spécial fatimata one
six ans que le festival nuits d'afrique
met à l'honneur la culture africaine à
travers sa musique mais aussi à travers
ses créations africaines présentés dans
ce marché de tombouctou ces deux cent
mille personnes qui viennent sur quinze
jours applaudir 700 artistes qui
viennent de 30 pays d'afrique et de la
caraïbe visiblement il ne s'en lasse pas
la diversité culturelle du continent
africain du maroc jusqu'au sud je viens
chaque année c'est vraiment des
festivals que j'adore le plus de
montréal ça nous plaît bien
la laddh jeunes à la très très bien
chanté à nous a fait danser vraiment
bravo pour leur organisation l'est tout
autant extraordinaire
côté musique la programmation est
éclectique et pointue on dit que les
plus grands noms se sont produits ici de
papa wemba à tiken jah fakoly en passant
par femi kuti mais l'organisation est un
véritable défi entre les demandes de
visas et les budgets toujours plus
important canton en europe exemple c'est
un pays après l'autre et tout est
condensé tandis qu'ici il faut créer des
circuits il faut des circuits avec
d'autres villes canadiennes et d'autres
villes américaines
et là les la logistique des visas qui
vient qui s'est alors dit beaucoup et
cette année c'est vraiment particulier
aussi ce festival est un véritable
tremplin pour les artistes africains qui
cherchent une scène qui va les propulser
à l'international ça représente beaucoup
de choses pour moi un artiste sénégalais
africains qui sort un album qui se nomme
peace in africa et là on a l'opportunité
de venir jouer cet album est ici dans le
grand festival nuits d'afrique il ya
quand même 20 ans que j'étais et je
reviens encore du don pour moi ça
signifie beaucoup d'être là et est là
aussi pour un sixième album qui est
sorti à peu près un an maintenant le
festival nuits d'afrique est aussi un
formidable dénicheur de talents comme ce
groupe qui joue en ce moment c'est un
groupe algérien qui revisite le chaabi
avec des touches de blues et le jazz ils
n'ont qu'un an d'existence et pourtant
ils mettent une ambiance dingue il
s'appelle scirocco
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal de
l'afrique merci beaucoup de l'avoir
suivi rester avec nous sur france 24
alain formation continue
[Musique]